свято he is fast обраний президент
трамп я впишу прес-конференцію після
виборів і у porsche викликавши що за
хакерським вкручуванням у вибори до США
коштувати russian что винтер на вашу
роботом а ось це кволий span smoby
я б у душі раді по трішки вина рости
ви знали зараз пройдусь їм
сповідання потім серйозну атаку на
вибори та дірк вітром би правильно за у
важливістю так ось і шукай країни на мага
ці роботи частина загинуть кондактив лише
радість even виставка самих росіян та
адже за видами за це відпалити це теган і
моєї дружини ступнями калгар дари господа
верстаті офіс sd до фактор для голови ну
година трамп здається що путін симпатію та
йому право а нині частки і що за
правлінні трампу путін будь вона багата
шульги ставлять асада США і не вдова томаті
до нових хакерських атак щоб процедура
[музика]
мої переконань володимир путін
у це сталося вин продукт кгб і
ви хрестового теми шкірно приволоку
зможе я вже бачу у трьох президентів
буша клінтон це обаму
equites вірив та зараз може ви буду у
цієї але who's the song is путіна геть та
хвалила його не бійся, джордж більше але
адже сказав я подавився by gucci та
побачивши в його душі так ось за
президентства обами була спроба при
завантажити вигляд але син із росії you
wish to a la minor і чому сама одразу мід
їх хто нас правді путін веселий нам
стриту повернутий ісида покличте честі в
рональда рейгана світ через силу і ден
шукаю шляхи ну зрозуміло сила
рахунку на агресію завжди віднімається не
вчить
він мову лімфоми ми майже з міру
та та crane так вами я ми відпочив я queen та
ручного в Україну забравши крим як за раз
ви хрестовий таки засвоїли б бомби чи то
карнівал і по русі весь до в
Калінінград і c список можна продовжувати
[музика]
савін робіть мій дуже економічно повинен
славка україну заплачемо, а там у нас
варто повернутися до політики світу через
силу
так ми будемо радіо говорити з володимиром
путіним
лиж з позиції цілий місяць а дональд
трамп одразу men's fashion house
зайчика ваші загальна і вираз вигляд
прес-конференції трампу там стався
конфлікт mesh трампом то cnn
винні в каналі пушери не фейкові
новий ось я алінка шик вище загальна
вислів про гримуар марк і про росію
такий акаунт грабуєш боїться врятував я мега
багатий ще позначилося пробую максимальну
коронку прибраний президента дональд
трамп зради у політичний стиль us
отриманих штатах за допомогою twitter
тасос маріш забула його перріша
прес-конференція здаєте за втомиться 5
місяців такого було враховано трамп і
знатні мобілізувати і свою базу
рингу
розум стем рейтинг і хопе trinken шукайте
нижче бутік оуен кроку американського
президента на мамонтів ступу на посаду
сюди свято сау з'ясуємо гаяне жовта
міні-маркеті теж ми постригаємо пеклі дружини
звучання годинник в американській політиці
то дуже поляризована америка я б хотіла
ніж трампа затиснувши на всіх американців
за лижну підсумку голосував Іван і за
його чиніть
of mine мою спиці теж на мінікарті
когось ще бін / хв досягнувши успіху в
політиці в kenshi маму писанку заголовним
автомат
їхав.